Ivik:
Godt. Så som jeg sagde, første halvdel her, det er simpelthen, hvor vi laver en.. vi opsætter et scenarie.
Så undersøgelsen handler egentlig om, at vi først skal finde ud af, hvor godt vores design viser information.
Ivik:
Så derfor skal du egentlig ikke interagere med noget, på nuværende tidspunkt.
Du skal egentlig bare svare på det spørgsmål, vi så stiller dig i forhold til det opstillede scenarie.
Ivik:
Så forestil dig du er på gangen, og kommer i tanke om, at du har brug for at booke et mødelokale,
mellem 14:30 og 15, derfor går du så hen til den nærmeste mødelokale,
Ivik:
og her lægger du mærke til at tabletten foran lokalet viset noget på skærmen.
Det første spørgsmål er: er der på nuværende sidspunktet møde i gang i lokalet.
Ole:
forudsat at det er den 27. Ja.
Ivik:
Ja. Er der andet, du kan se på skærmen?
Ole:
Ja, jeg kan se et møde der er fra kl 12 til 13, og det er Mia der har mødet.
Ivik:
Ja. Okay, super.
Ole:
Og der er en bookning igen fra kl 13 til 15.
Ivik:
Ja.
Ole:
Så der er en hul på 15 minutter.
Ivik:
Ja. Er der andet på skærmen, som viser, eller indikerer, om der er et møde i gang i lokalet på nuværende tidspunkt?
Ole:
jaa.. Der er en indikator, hvor langt vi har så.. brugt process indikator hernede.
*Peger på timeline*
Ole:
Det er sådan det eneste jeg lige umiddelbart..
Ivik:
Okay.
Ole:
Og så står der occupied ik'.
Ivik:
Ja, super. Det var den jeg fiskede efter.
Og du har så egentlig også nævnet, hvem der har booket det nuværende møde, der sagde du Mia.
Ivik:
Og så har du egentlig også indikeret, at lokalet egentlig er ledig mellem 14:30 og 15, så det er egentlig super.
Godt. Så går vi lige hen til det andet scenarie så skal jeg lige..
Ole:
Kl 14.30 til 15?
arh, 14:15 til 16.
*Peger på det næste møde og så over på mødet efter for at vise tidsrummet*
Ivik:
Det er en fejl fra vores side af.
Ole:
Ja, det okay.
Ivik:
Så gør vi lige sådan her..
*Skifter skærmen til available*
Og sådan der..
Ivik:
Ja, så det andet scenarie er.. hvad hedder det.. At det.. Nu skal jeg lige ser her.
Ja, du vil vil gerne..
Marco:
Scenarie to er det ikke?
Ivik:
har jeg smidt den..
Der.
*Fandt scenariet*
Ivik:
Okay, så du konkluderer lokalet ikke er tilgængeligt i det tidsrum, du skal holde møde
Og derfor går du hen til nabolokalet, som også er et mødelokal,
Ivik:
og så er spørgsmålet så, er det her lokale ledigt nu.
Ole:
Vil du have det frække svar?
Ivik:
Ja.
Ole:
Det er det, fordi det hedder det samme som det andet lokale, på samme tidspunkt.
*Refererer til at lokalet ikke har ændret navn på trods af at det skulle være et andet lokale*
Ole:
Det er den ene ting. Men hvis det var det andet lokale, ja, det er ledigt.
Ivik:
Godt.
Øh, og hvornår er det næste møde i det her lokale?
Ole:
Det er kl 12.
Ivik:
Super.
Ole:
til 13.
Ivik:
Ja.
Og er det muligt, at booke lokalet med 14.30 og kl. 15?
Ole:
Det ville være muligt, ja.
Ivik:
Super.
Godt.
Ivik:
Jamen, det var egentlig scenarierne.
Så, hvad hedder det..
Ivik:
Så har vi jo så, som jeg nævnte før, nogle opgaver.
Og nu skal jeg lige sikre mig, at der er styr på...
Ivik:
Fordi der var to typer opgaver.
Ole:
Nu skal du huske på at jeg er den dumme sælger, så jeg skal have den nemme.
Ivik:
Ja, ja, jamen, det.. he he..
Det er fordi der er egentlig opgaver til den grønne og den røde skærm.
Ivik:
Nu skal jo lige se, hvad der var hvad.
Ole:
Jeg syntes det er et meget fedt design i har lavet.
Patrick:
Tak for det.
Ole:
Det syntes jeg. Den er meget forklarende når du har den her bar, her i bunden.
*Peger på timeline*
Patrick:
Ja.
Ivik:
Okay.
Så det passer egentlig med hvor vi er.
Ivik:
Så skal du egentlig bare løse opgaverne og tænke højt.
Ole:
du skal booke et møde, som skal afholdes med Mia Østergaard.
*Læser opgaven højt*
Ole:
Du skal booke mødet mellem 14.30 og 15.
*Læser opgaven Højt*
Ole:
Og invitere Mia.
*Læser opgaven Højt*
Ole:
Jamen, da det jo ikke er.
*Gestikulerer mod tabletten*
Ole:
Men så kan jeg jo så trykke på schedule møde, taste min tidsramme ind, den er 14:30 til 15..
Ivik:
Og du kan faktisk interagere med...
Ole:
Nå, det kan man godt.
*Trykker på schedule*
Patrick:
Det er lidt en hi-fi-prototype.
Så det er ikke den endelige system, nej.
Patrick:
Men den kan noget.
Ole:
*Prøver at vælge tid, men det er ikke implementeret*
Ivik:
Ja, så på det her tidspunkt, der vil, tidspunktet allerede være indsat for dig. Det fik jeg ikke lige sagt.
Patrick:
Det skal du ændre på tiden, nej.
Så du egentlig bare...
Patrick:
Hov, Hvad er der sket nu?
*Skærmen er blevet mørk*
Vi er løbet tør for strøm.
Ivik:
Den tænker.
Patrick:
Det har jeg ikke set for.
Ivik:
Prøv at trykke ok.
Ole:
Jeg kan se go back
Det prøver vi.
Patrick:
gad vide om det er wifi'et.
Ivik:
Det er typisk, når man så...
*Skærmen bliver lys igen*
Ole:
Jeg er tilbage nu.
Host det må være her jeg skal sætte mit navn ind.
*Trykker på host feltet, men den reagerer ikke*
Ole:
Hvis jeg kunne, det kan jeg så ikke.
Ivik:
Jeg prøver lige at holde to fingre inde og så restart den
Patrick:
Jeg ved ikke lige, hvorfor..
Ja prøv lige hurtigt at genstarte den. Jeg syntes den opfører sig mærkeligt.
Patrick:
Jeg prøver lige en gang mere.
Ole:
Skal jeg prøve at rette tiden?
Patrick:
Prøv bare at trykke på host.
Ole:
Jeg prøver at trykke på host.
*Trykker på host, men skærmen bliver mørk igen*
Det kan jeg ikke.
Patrick:
Jo, det kan du, men det er simpelthen wifi'et.
Den kan ikke indlæs, den næste på grund af wifi'et.
Ole:
Er det så dårligt?
Patrick:
Det må det åbenbart være. For det virkede fint da vi prøvede det på uni.
Marco:
skal jeg prøve at lave et hotspot.
Ole:
Ja, prøv det.
Så skal du lige ud af den der Patrick.
*Rykker tabletten over mod Patrick*
Ole:
Så ind på et andet wifi.
Patrick:
Nåh ja, så skal vi.. Jeg stopper bare lige den her.